okay cool uh let's just get started uh welcome everyone to lecture 12 um so you know so far we've learned a lot about how uh like you know we convert words into vectors how we convert sentences into vectors and you know uh basically uh take actions in the real world using that so like classify documents uh we learned about uh you know Transformers we learned about pre-training today is going to be a little bit different uh I'm going to be talking about how you can train large models on gpus and a few Basics about
how you know these ml systems work and it's it has nothing to do with natural language at all but hopefully it's going to be useful for final projects um so I'm going to spend some time on mixed Precision training uh some time on multi-gpu training with DDP and Fs DP and hopefully by the end of the lecture these terms will make sense and sometime on parameter efficient fine-tuning uh but before we get into the lecture uh just some announcements uh proposal grades are going to be coming out shortly uh
hopefully by the end of the day uh thank you so much for all the hard work I know you know it's kind of getting a little bit crammed with you know a lot of deadlines for assignment 4 and the project proposal so thank you so much for for all your hard work uh the other thing is the project Milestone uh details should be out shortly if not already out on the website um so it's worth 5% of the overall grade uh it's due 12 days from now and it's a maximum of two pages and really the way to think
about the Milestone is to use this as a forcing function to get work done for your final project um and yeah uh with that out of the way let's just jump into into the material uh so I'm going to start by thinking about how parameters and gradients and generally numbers are represented in computers uh and I promise it's going to be relevant to to deep learning pretty soon so let's start with uh floating Point uh how many people here are familiar with this cartoon depiction of fp32 can you just
get okay so some of you so yeah let's let's kind of recap how floating points are represented in computers uh so so firstly fp32 that's like 32 bytes so the memory requirement is it's 32 bits so the memory requirement is 4 bytes okay and so if you're thinking about neural networks then for every single neural net parameters you need four bytes of GPU memory and the way to convert this cartoon into a real number is something like this uh so the first bit there is the sign and then the stuff in green
represents the range and then the stuff in blue represents Precision okay um and and yeah and and so for fp32 you know there's like uh you can represent like a pretty large range and it's fairly precise right um and so the larger the stuff in green is the more numbers you can represent which means more smaller numbers and also like larger numbers and the more stuff in green uh the more stuff in blue we have the greater appr Precision in representing actual numbers okay um so another popular data type
that takes half the memory of fp32 is fp16 and uh the way we reduce memory is we're going to reduce uh the stuff in green so there's going to be less range less dynamic range and also the stuff in blue which means it's going to be uh less Precision okay but the good uh thing is that we can save memory so you know we slash memory requirements in half so uh let's think of a scenario where you know you're trying to train a big neural network and your model parameters and gradients are represented
in fp32 you start training and suddenly you get uh an out of memory Cuda error okay and so just based on you know what we've seen so far one possible solution is you cast everything into fp16 okay and if you do that you reduce memory usage by half um so let's kind of work through what are some possible problems with doing something like that uh so you know like I said uh because there's less stuff in green there's going to be less range and so that means uh a lot of uh very small numbers will get uh converted
to zero and a lot of really large numbers will get converted into n okay and there's also less Precision because you have less bits in in in blue which means you're going to get rounding errors um for example uh 1.1 gets converted to one uh in half Precision uh and I have a little uh screenshot of how you can test uh various properties of data types right so um basically the things to to to to look at are the Epsilon the Epsilon is like the smallest number such that if you add that to one you don't lose any
Precision if you add a number that's smaller than Epsilon to one that gets just round rounded down to one and the smallest normal is the smallest number that can be presented in uh uh fp16 anything smaller than that it goes straight to zero okay and uh for neural network training if a lot of small numbers get rounded down to zero uh that's actually not good so here's a diagram that I took from uh an Nvidia blog post that's just showing um just sort of some gradients during the course
of training and more than half of these gradients will literally just get set to zero in in fp16 uh which is kind of a problem um and uh that has to do with the range of fb16 and the second problem is uh with Precision right so we have basically uh less precision and so our updates are not going to be precise okay so uh the solution here's one possible solution right so uh we're going to use fp16 but we also going to use fp32 okay so that's that's sort of the high level idea uh and what we're
going to do is we're going to maintain uh a copy of the model in fp32 and let's call those Master weights and then uh you get a little bit of data you run a forward pass um and then when you run your forward pass you run it by uh converting from fp32 into fp16 okay and then uh you get a gradient run a backward pass and then get your gradient in fp16 okay so everything so far has happened in fp16 then you take your gradients upcast them into fp32 and then update your master weights and then once you update your master
weights you copy them into the fp16 version of the neural network okay so this seems like a reasonable scheme you know I'm using fp16 on my GPU but I have the full sort of uh 32-bit Precision also lying around somewhere so I can have more precise updates okay uh can someone tell me why this is still problematic any guesses yeah uh one would be like really slow because you have to copy like the 32 bit versions from like GPU into like some yeah so so that's a good point so you can often like overlap uh IO with
like forward and backward passes so practically this is not a problem but yeah that's a good point potentially if your network is very very small this would be a problem yeah gradients are usually fairly small like individual gradients are usually Fair small and when you copy the fp6 computed Radiance onto fp32 you may be sending your network somewhere else where you don't want it to so yeah so that's that's pretty much pretty much the right answer so you know let's kind of uh go back to this diagram
that we had uh so this shows gradients in the backward pass and you know I said that we're going to compute all our gradients in fp16 what's going to happen like most of them will just get converted to zero okay which is which is something that we really would like to avoid okay so here's a possible solution so what you can do is you can you get your batch of data you run your forward pass in fp16 you compute your gradient uh but then when you have the uh sorry so we here um so you get a batch of data
you compute a forward pass in fp16 you get your loss you scale the loss by some large value okay let's say 100 let's say a th000 and then you compute gradients and now you just like scale your gradient by a large number and so everything that we had on the left hand side of this red line just gets shifted to the right and hopefully there's less stuff that will uh get rounded down to zero okay and then compute your gradient in fp16 copy it into fp32 and then divided by the scaling factor and then you
update your master widths okay uh so this will solve uh both the problems that we talked about okay and so this is basically uh what we call Precision training okay and it's relatively simple to implement this in pytorch uh all you have to do is uh you need to instantiate this grad scalar uh uh object and then um within the context of like this AutoCast you want to run your forward and backward passes and then um scale down your gradient uh and then uh update your model parameters okay uh but then this seems a little
complex you know we have to deal with sort of scaling the loss uh and then scaling it back down what if you multiplied it by 10,000 and that leads to nans and so then you have to kind of scale uh you have to update your scaler you have to like in the next iteration multiply by th000 you know and you have to kind of adjust to to sort of network Dynamics okay so we'd like to not do gradient scaling um so can we do something better okay so uh the reason we why we have to do the scaling is you know just recall uh sort of the role of
uh of sort of the bits in green that kind of tells you what is the dynamic range of the data type and we needed scaling because fp16 has a small much smaller range compared to fp32 right um and so because of that fp16 cannot represent very small numbers okay so how do we solve this any ideas yeah so uh here's the problem right so in fp16 because you have fewer bits for the exponent you can't represent very small numbers so if you have something that's smaller than I don't know 6 e
minus 5 it gets uh down uh sort of uh uh rounded down to zero and that's because of the dynamic range of fp16 so how do you solve that sacrifice Precision so have more green absolutely yeah so that's that's the right answer uh so what we're going to do is we're going to sacrifice uh Precision so uh that's the idea for B float 16 which stands for brain float 16 um so you're going to have exactly the same number of bits for representing the range so that's going to be eight bits
so has the same dynamic range as fp32 but a lot less precision and it turns out that this this is okay for neural network training okay and now if you use B float 16 you don't need to use uh grad scalers anymore it's it's as simple as wrapping your model forward pass and backward pass uh within the right uh context uh the one caveat about B flat 16 is that it's not available on all gpus so you need to have the latest sort of ampere uh Nvidia architectures which the h100s the a100 the a6000 have uh but
if you have like a older GPU then you might not be able to utilize B FL 16 sorry can you why having less Precision but the same amount of eits um yeah so it's B 6 and oh never mind sorry I'm uh so here are some um kind of results um so someone uh find you in dist bir for sentiment classification on a single a 100 um at the very top is float 64 which is like you know really really rich 64bit representation of floating points it takes about 25 minutes um and you get a pretty high accuracy but it also takes a lot more
memory okay and all the way down we're using mixed Precision training with B float 16 and now we have reduced staining Time by roughly a third um more or less have the same accuracy a little bit better actually because there's some regularizing effect from U the you know half bit uh the half Precision representation and then a lot less memory okay uh and the reason we see speedups for training is because Matrix multiplies tend to be faster when you are multiplying in half Precision okay so uh before we move on
are there any questions about about this Okay cool so uh let's let's keep going and uh let's sort of change the setting right so now now we have more than one GPU now we have multiple gpus and we want to train a network or all of the multiple gpus that we have Okay so let's start with some Basics okay so uh here's a cartoon showing uh basically a model and an Optimizer uh receiving some data from a data set okay and let's kind of work through what's stored on GPU vram okay
and this is going to be some what of a lie and I will I I will point out what my lie is soon uh but you know just to keep things simple uh we have the neural net parameters okay so let's say we're doing mixed procure training and so it's stored in fp16 and then we have an Optimizer okay and uh you know when I first saw this uh you know few years back I was very surprised to see that optimizers also need memory but uh if you're using something like Adam uh then you need to store the adom momentum term and the
adom variance and every time you get a gradient you have to update adom momentum and variance and that's what you use uh for updating your parameters and because you're using mixed Precision training these have to be represented in sort of um fp32 okay uh so so that's that that's that's what the picture looks like if you have a single GPU now let's say we have multiple gpus okay and what we'd like to do is is uh first divide our data set into let's say we have four GPS right so we'll divide our
data set into four parts and we'll maintain a synchronized copy of the model uh and every model receives its own slice of the data set okay um in the beginning we have a synchronized model and everyone has their own copy we run a forward pass okay so this forward pass receives different data points and so every model is going to have different activations and correspondingly every model is going to have different gradients okay so you run a backward pass every model has a different gradient because there's
different data points and then we're going to run a synchronization step and what synchronization is going to do is communicate gradients between between different workers okay and so I'm going to introduce the first sort of uh MPI primitive in this lecture and that primitive is called the all reduce operation what all ruse does is it takes um four pieces of uh information on in this example on four different gpus it sort of merges everything together and then uh distributes it to all of the
gpus okay and the communication overhead of doing that is two bytes per parameter because remember we have uh fp16 gradients okay so two bytes per gradient and then uh this needs to be communicated um and so the overhead is 2 bytes per parameter okay so that's the all reduce operation uh and then once gradients have been communicated so they have to be communicated by you know sort of gathering on one worker and just sort of Distributing the cumulative gradient at that point uh every Optimizer has the
full gradient and then the optimizer can you know update the model so that you maintain synchronization okay so that's the basic that's uh that's known as distributed data parallel okay um that's good uh but turns out that it has really poor memory scaling so let's kind of go through our math for how many uh how much memory is needed right so uh we have the model parameters that's fp16 because we're doing mixed Precision training and then for the gradient we also have the
gradient in fp16 right so two bytes uh for the gradient and then we have the stuff in green the stuff in green is let's say we're doing adom so we need to well we need to store the master waste regardless of whether we're doing adom or not and then we need to store the momentum and the variance okay so that's 12 extra bytes uh per parameter okay and this needs to be stored on every single GPU okay um and so the question is can we do better than this okay and so now uh things are going to get a little bit
more tricky so if you have questions just stop me um and you know we can we can go from there so um the way we're going to improve uh our memory sort of scaling is we are a set of techniques uh that are together known as zero that stands for zero redundancy Optimizer so this was uh you know a set of techniques released by Microsoft as part of their deep speed project okay and the idea is going to be that we are going to instead instead of having every GPU contain all of this state so by the state I mean the
stuff in blue the stuff in Orange and the stuff in green you're going to sort of Shard it okay so there's there's there's going to be uh shards so that not every GPU has all of the parameters or all of the gradient but by communication they can sort of synchronize okay so that's pretty much what uh the the the uh sketch for this is going to look like okay so let's look at stage one so like zero has like multiple stages so there's stage one 1 two and three in stage one we're going
to Shard uh the stuff in green so stuff in green was the optimizer State um and so the way we're going to Shard and still maintain synchronization is something like this okay so every GPU has um you know uh the full set of parameters in fp16 and every GPU has its its gradient for its data okay but it only has a sharded copy of the full Optimizer State and the the the other requirement is that every GPU is responsible for updating the parameters corresponding to its own Shard okay so if you go step by
step this is what it looks like uh every every GPU has its own data uh every GPU gets a gradient on its subset of the data okay then we perform a reduced scatter so now this is the second uh MPI operation of the lecture so we've we've done all reduce this is the second one this is called reduce scatter uh what A reduced scatter does is every GPU has uh the full gradient on its data and what you want to do is you want to take the chunk corresponding to let's say GPU 1 so let's say your GPU 0 and you've
computed the full gradient for all the parameters and you want to communicate uh your uh the chunk for GPU 1 to GPU 1 okay and same for GPU 2 and three okay so what you're going to do is from the full gradient just communicate the bits that a different worker wants to that worker okay and every GPU has to do that so that's called a reduced scatter okay and then once every worker gets uh the gradient corresponding to its Shard they're going to update its parameters and then once they have
updated their Shard they're going to sort of perform an all gather so what that means is let's say you have a neural network with just let's say eight parameters uh two parameters on each GPU at the end of this uh each GPU has updated their subset of parameters and then they're going to sort of do an all gather to just sort of maintain synchronization so every GPU gets the full set of parameters that are all updated yeah is maintaining this and you're not merging them together in that
way um what is what makes this more efficient um sorry could you repeat your question can you go over why this is better than doing the prion right so uh what we're going to do is uh Shard the optimizer state right so let's say in a running example we have a neural network with eight parameters okay earlier uh we needed the optimizer state for all of the eight parameters now every GPU has to maintain Optimizer state for only two parameters okay so after the reduced scatters are done you have the full uh
gradient corresponding to just two parameters okay so the optimizer state is just uh the gradient for two parameters the model is going to update only two parameters using the partial uh uh sort of Optimizer state but you have to have the entire set of parameters to run so you'll eventually get the rest of the parameters back so you have the entire set of parameters you have all the stuff in blue and you have the full grad for your subset but you don't have the full Optimizer state so what you can do is
you can only update the parameters for the bits of Optimizer State you have okay so in a running example that I just made up uh you know gp0 updates two parameters gpu1 updates two parameters and so on okay and then they communicate updated parameters to maintain synchronization okay more questions about this okay so let's keep going so so so far we have looked at three MPI operations we looked at um all gather we looked at reduce scatter and we looked at all reduce okay so turns out that um all
reduce is actually equivalent to running a reduced scatter followed by an all gather operation and just recall that like for DD P all we had to do was this all reduce operation and we commun we we computed what's the communication overhead of that and turns out that when you're doing this Optimizer State sharding you have to do exactly the same amount of communication overhead just because an all reduce is equivalent to a reduce scatter followed by an all gather okay and so we basically saved memory
for free okay so just I mean you should just always use this okay um because you going to get memory savings and you don't have any additional communication overhead okay so we happy we saved memory and now you know we want to Shard even more things okay so let's let's start doing zero stage two uh and now along with sharding the stuff in green which was my Optimizer state I'm also going to Shard gradients okay and now this is going to be a little bit more complex because um we kind of still need
need the full gradient for the workers's data slice okay but each GPU only has enough memory for um instantiating the gradient for a small subset of parameters so how are we going to deal with that so we are actually never going to instantiate the full gradient vector and then whenever a GPU gets um a gradient in the backward pass you instantiate uh a vector sort of temporarily for the parameter for which you just received a gradient and then compute the gradient and then just send it to the right
worker and then you destroy the memory that you just created okay that's kind kind of the sketch and let's kind of go through this step by step okay so um we have four workers okay each worker performs a backward pass and the backward pass happens layer by layer right so uh recall the lecture on uh Auto diff so you have the loss and then you have this back backward passw layer by layer you compute gradients okay so now let's say you're at layer J you take the Upstream gradient you compute
gradient for the parameters at ler okay immediately the moment you compute those gradients send it to the right worker okay so there exists some worker that is responsible for ler okay and what's going to happen is every GPU that's just computed uh the gradient for layer J for its data slice sends it to the right worker okay uh and then the moment you've done that you deallocate this memory that you just created okay uh and so uh this is kind of uh a fourth MPI operation but really not very different
from a reduce CER this is just a reduce so there are four gpus uh that have a gradient and then they just have to communicate it to whoever is responsible for maintaining gradient for that layer okay um and then yeah so there exists some worker that is responsible for a given layer they're going to update uh its parameter Shard using uh the full gradient that it received via this communication along with the optimizer State okay and then at the end to synchronize everything you have to perform in all gather as
before okay uh any any questions about about uh this like high level sketch okay so so let's keep moving um okay so recall that uh for zero stage one um it was basically free because uh turns out that an all reduce is equivalent to a reduce scatter plus an all gather and we're kind of doing the same thing here we have a reduce followed by an all gather so this is practically also for free Okay so we've gotten away with saving memory without any communication overhead compared to DDP so far okay so let's
keep going let's let's try and see if we can Shard even more things okay uh and I think someone sort of alluded to this in the audience early on so what happens if you Shard even your model parameters okay so let's say you run into a situation where uh you know forget about the optimizer State even your model wouldn't fit on a single GPU and so in that that case what you do is you split up your model so you split up your model across all the different gpus so you Shard your model parameters which
is the stuff in blue um uh but the caveat is that now we're not going to get uh this for free we're not going to get memory savings for free there's going to be some communication overhead okay and uh this is zero stage three this is the final stage of zero this is also known as fsdp fully shoted data parallel for uh anyone who's heard that term before um and here's sort of the high level sketch okay and I feel like uh this is kind of the easiest to understand compared to zero stage one and two um
just because there needs to be communication at every step of the way right you can't get away uh without communicating so the first thing we're going to do is we're going to take our model and we're going to convert the entire model into fsdp units Okay so here's a sketch um a simple deep neural network I'm going to convert that into multiple fsdp units uh three fsdp units here okay so that's that's just a data structure an fsdp unit okay we've not done anything so far uh and then I have
this fsdp unit I'm going to convert this into another data structure called a flat parameter and then I'm going to uh assign a subset of these parameters to every single GP okay so here we have 16 gpus and a flat parameter consisting of 14 parameters plus some extra padding so that uh things divide properly and I'm going to assign each parameter to uh a distinct GPU okay and so that's basically just a complex way of saying that we created some data structures and we just like divided up model parameters
uh to every GPU okay so every GPU gets a subset of model parameters um okay now let's start thinking about what my forward pass would look like so there's no GPU that has the full set of parameters okay so you're running a forward pass let's say you're at layer 4 now there's no GPU that has all of layer 4 so you have to communicate uh so we need to do an all gathered operation that's the operation that we did to um you know uh cumulate multiple things that are on multiple
gpus uh so that every GPU has the full thing uh so you perform an all gather so that all so you have all pieces of layer four you run a forward pass okay and now you don't need layer four so you now discard your parameter shards okay and now you have to run your backward pass right so you computed your loss and now you have to do a backward pass uh again uh let's say you are back at layer four you have your Upstream gradient uh you don't have layer four so you need to do another all gather so you
get all the parameters of layer four um and then you uh run a backward pass for layer Force you compute the gradient for your subset of parameters so recall that every GPU has different data points right so there's going to be different gradients for every GPU okay so then for layer four uh you do an all gather get all parameters computer gradient every GPU has different gradients and then you have to do a reduce scatter so that uh you can send the full gradient to the GPU that's responsible for whatever
parts of layer 4 uh that that that you're sending okay so yeah so so that's basically uh full fsdp um and then once you uh once you sort of run the forward and backward pass then each GPU will update its own parameter Shard using the full gradient that it received just now um and then you do a synchronization right so let's kind of do a quick review of everything we've looked at so far um so there was DDP um which was you don't shot anything you have the full model full gradient
the full Optimizer State on every single GPU and all you're going to divide up is the full data set right so you have a big data set of 1,000 examples every GPU gets 250 examples okay and then you compute a forward pass and a backward pass every GPU has a different gradient you need to communicate that gradient and then you synchronize okay and so that was called an all reduce operation uh in MPI terms and then we looked at zero which is now we want to save some memory we don't want uh the full sort of
memory requirements of models gradients and Optimizer State on every single GPU and in zero stage one we shouted the optimizer state so that there is uh you know so that you don't have to maintain the full Optimizer state for every GPU you kind of break that down between all the different gpus that you have and we saw that the communication overhead of maintaining synchronization in zero stage one boiled down to basically just doing an all reduce through this uh identity that says that an all reduce is
a reduce scatter plus an all gather okay and we save memory for free with zero stage one and two so you should just do it uh you know um and then with zero stage three things got a little bit more complex uh because you have to divide up your model parameters the optimizer State and the gradient and so while you're running your forward pass you kind of have to do some communication to get the full parameters for for any layer for layer four uh in in our example and then also have to do an all
Gather in the backward pass so you get the full gradient and then you have to do a reduce scatter so that you can send the full gradient for whatever chunk of the parameter to the right GPU and uh over overall that's like two all gathers plus a reduced scatter so that's a lot more overhead uh than stages one and two but if you don't uh have enough GPU vram so that you can even load your model onto a GPU then this is kind of what you have to do um all right uh any questions about MPI Primitives or stages of of
zero or fsdp okay cool um so I'm going to fix the lie that uh that I said earlier about the GPU vram calculation um so I said that there's just like model parameters and gradients uh and the optimizer state but there's this thing there this like final thing the model Activation so like you know we've all seen that uh as you keep you know you you want to increase the bat size uh and there's a point when the GPU say says that it can't fit more stuff and that's because you also need
to store model activations in the backward pass right uh and that scales linearly with the bath size okay so the larger the bath size the more the number of model activations that need to be stored uh and by the way if you're doing mixed Precision this is in fp16 or bf16 but it scales with the bat size okay and so uh that's sort of the other thing that you have to think about and you know you uh none of the techniques that we've looked at so far help with uh kind of Shing model activations um so okay so we looked at a
bunch of like um you know basics of like multi-gpu uh training and you know like floating point but it kind of boils down to this very simple flowchart which you can use for your final projects when you're fine tuning models so the first thing is always use mixed Precision training you know you barely ever see a a hit in performance uh by performance I mean like generalization or like you know F1 or accuracy and if you're using the newer ampere architectures the the h100s or the A1 100s or the a6000 always use BF
float 16 uh it's just better um and you can check that with with that torch command um okay so always use mixed Precision training now uh ask yourself this question does bat size one fit on a a single GPU okay if it fits and try a larger bat size okay bat size one is too small uh try a larger bat size and or use zero stage two okay zero stage two is for free just use a zero stage two and increase your bat size if you can't fit even bat size one uh then you have to see if zero stage three fixes your
out of memory issues cuz now you're going to Shard your model parameters okay and all of this is is in the context of full fine tuning right so I'm fine tuning all of my model parameters okay sometimes the answer to that question is also no so you can't full fine tune your model on four whatever A1 100s or you know a6000 um and you've tried zero stage three you've start you've tried mixed Precision training uh you have a bat size of one maybe you did gradient checkpoint pointing activation
checkpointing and nothing works and so now uh basically you can't do full fine tuning and so the thing to do is to try parameter efficient fine-tuning okay and that's going to give you a lot more uh memory savings okay so let's talk about parameter efficient fine tuning okay um so why is it called parameter refer in fine tuning so in full fine tuning uh you know you run a forward pass and a backward pass and you update every single model parameter and in parameter efficient fine-tuning you're
only going to update a small subset of the full uh set of parameters okay and uh why would you want to do that so uh you know maybe you're in a setting where you cannot full fine tune even with bat size one you've tried all the tricks possible uh it just wouldn't fit uh and so maybe you have to do parameter efficient fine tuning um maybe the other possible reason why you want to do it is kind of slightly more scientific uh you know these like models these days are heavily overparameterized uh and you have a
small data set and you you believe that if you do parameter efficient F tuning uh then you can get a better like generalization okay um or you believe that you know it's going to match for fine tuning okay uh sort of a second reason for wanting to do f adaptation um so uh the plot on the right here shows uh in in red it's sort of the estimated growth uh in training compute for training the largest AI models and uh the line in blue is the global compute capacity so very soon we are going to overshoot the global
compute capacity and going to need a lot more compute than you know the global capacity and so this is kind of not sustainable um and you know there's there there are arguments to be made about how uh if we keep going down this route then you know AI development becomes concentrated in only the hands of a few well-funded organizations and you know as students we can't do it um and so that's a problem and then also like if there's only a small number of players that are training and fine-tuning models then
they may bias the model in specific ways that reflect their value systems and not sort of the the broader uh public um and so that's another reason to do full uh to to think about efficient adaptation um and there's sort of this Paradigm in in in machine learning in general and NLP uh specifically to focus uh a lot on on accuracy instead of efficiency and so the pro on the right here shows um the percentage of papers where where the main contribution is a method that produces just you know more accurate
models versus methods that produce same accuracy for more efficiency um and so we can see that for most conferences the vast majority of papers are about accuracy there's very few papers about efficiency okay um and and so maybe this is kind of leading to this like monoculture and maybe that's why we want to focus on efficiency uh the second maybe bigger sort of concern is that there's this huge uh hidden environmental cost of of training and fine-tuning large language models uh so I was just reading some report where
where they said that the cost of training gpt3 was equivalent to 1.1 million tons of carbon emission or some some some some some such number and they they kind of estimated that that's the cost of running a Coal Power Plant for 10 hours straight okay um all right uh and and uh for an example closer to home um in in in the reinforcement learning class um there was like uh you know the final project no not the final project a homework assignment and um you know a lot of students implemented uh kind of a common
algorithm uh one uh one or two algorithms that sort of outperformed everything else it used a lot more power okay and someone did this calculation that if everyone had used the most efficient algorithm that would have uh uh sorry if everyone had used the more efficient algorithm that would have reduced the power consumption of the Class by about 880 kilowatt hours which is what an American household uses in a month okay so so there's another like the you know these are all reasons to think about like efficiency and like how
you can um like fine tune your models with like uh less resources okay uh so let's let's kind of jump back into like parameter efficient fine tuning okay and let's let's start by recapping what full fine tuning is um any questions so far about any of this okay um so yeah so let's recap full fine tuning so let's say we have some large uh pre-trained Auto regressive language model um let's say it's a GPT um and maybe we want to to use it for summarization maybe we want it for
semantic parsing so like converting natural language to SQL commands or maybe we want it to answer questions about paragraphs okay and what do we do we collect a data set of XY Pairs and then we do full fine tuning in full fine tuning we are going to update all of the model parameters based on the gradient for some loss function okay um and maybe that's not feasible uh GPD 3 has 175 billion parameters and so there's just like lot more parameters to learn and even once you have done full fine tuning
uh you kind of have to store all of the parameters and if you're doing like several tasks you have to store parameters for every task okay uh so can we do better um okay so the main idea is instead of updating all of the parameters I am going to update um a much smaller number of parameters okay uh and and then instead of uh finding sort of a Delta Theta which is the same size as the entire set of parameters I have to search over a much smaller space uh and then the added benefit is uh I can store this much smaller Delta
uh pretty easily on disk and hopefully it's going to require less compute and hopefully it's going to generalize almost as well as full fine tuning okay um so there's many different ways of um kind of operationalizing this high level idea of of parameter efficient fine tuning uh the one I'm going to talk about today is Laura okay so that stands for uh low rank adaptation and uh that basically comes from this observation that when you have uh big language models that you fine tune often times when you look at sort
of the um the like geometric structure of the gradients they tend to have a low intrinsic rank okay um do people remember Rank and SD all right okay so um so these parameters uh so the the gradients tend to have a low intrinsic rank okay and so what the authors real realized is instead of uh fine-tuning the entire set of parameters you could instead fine-tune a much smaller let's say rank R Matrix for every uh full rank Matrix that exists in the model okay so let's say we have uh some pre-trained weight
Matrix W KN and what I'm going to do is instead of applying some kind of arbitrary update I'm going to make sure that the update it has this following form okay so it's going to be the product of two low rank matrices b and a okay so a is in R uh in R is is an R cross K uh Matrix and B is a d cross R Matrix okay and R is is the rank much much smaller than either the um the uh sort of uh incoming Dimension and much much smaller than the outgoing Dimension okay and the term Alpha you can think of that as some
kind of trade-off between uh the knowledge that's already stored in the pre-rain model versus some additional knowledge that you want to add into the model okay so if Alpha is zero then you're not doing anything if Alpha is something really really small then you don't really want to change your model parameters all that much and you want to add some really small task specific knowledge um and then additionally the only trainable parameter s here are going to be a and b okay um okay um and then uh sort of the other
thing to note about this is uh since I'm representing updates as this product u b * a as I increase R that's going to converge towards full fine tuning right so you kind of have the slider that you can use to control how much fine tuning you want to do is essentially um and then uh the other important thing is uh inference latency so what you can do is uh you can just store these learned matrices for every task and whenever you switch to a different task uh you can just uh you can just remove
the extra term that you've added to every Matrix for that task and add in sort of the task specific terms for the new task that you want to run inference on okay and and the cost of like storing these like much smaller matrices is also way lower than storing uh sort of the full Delta okay um and we'll kind of see where you should apply Laura but like generally you want to apply it to uh the weight matrixes in self attention okay so um in code it actually looks fairly simple um so what you're going to do is uh when
you're running uh the regular forward pass then you sort of uh you know just like compute the hidden State as let's say the product of uh The Matrix and the incoming feature uh Vector now with Laura what you're going to do is you're going to freeze your model parameters you're going to compute the H as before and then to that you're going to add this additional offset term and that's the only thing that's going to be uh trainable okay and that's pretty much all you have to do we have to do it for
every single like weight Matrix uh for every single layer okay um but yeah so there's like an alpha term in the second to last line where do you define Alpha in the rest or do you just like put it somewhere uh so you so so yeah so you define the somewhere uh if you set it to one that's like saying that uh I kind of want um uh like an equal trade-off between pre-trained knowledge and the new task specific knowledge typically people set it to one you could set it to something larger than one if you believe
your task is something that the model uh the pre- model has no idea about uh or something smaller than one if you don't want to change the model too much um so so that's basically Laura um in practice so I said there's a bunch of different uh parameter efficient fine Heering methods right so uh I'm not even going to name all of these uh there's adapters some of you might have heard about adapters uh there is uh bitfit which is not here um and so there's like lots of different like ptuning um but it turns
out that like compared to a lot of these different uh methods it's it's kind of like uh you know pretty high high performing uh on a bunch of different tasks uh for these like relatively smaller models okay um and then if we try and look at uh some of the bigger like we're trying to fine tune some of the bigger models like GPD 3 uh and then compare it with other parameter efficient fine tuning methods um so full fine tuning is is is at the is at the way top then we have bit fit uh which is
you only fine tune the bias terms um and and adapters compared to that uh firstly Laura requires a lot fewer additional parameters that you need to store uh and it kind of gives you a good tradeoff for accuracy compared to full fine tuning and sometimes there's a regularizing effect uh from fine tuning only small subset of your model parameters um okay so uh you know the question is like for every uh Matrix you can apply Laura and I said that you want to apply it to the various um learned uh bit matrices
in site self attention the question is what uh what parameters uh you want to apply Lura to and uh generally the rule of the thumb is that if you apply it to the Matrix that takes your hidden State and converts that into queries and the Matrix that converts your hidden State into values apply Lura to those and that's pretty much going to give you the best performance overall um the other hyperparameter for Laura is the optimal rank so recall that these like two matrices b and a that are both like low
rank and turns out that like already with a a really small uh rank you can get a pretty high performance okay and this is much much smaller than um sort of the Hidden State dimensions of most of the matrices for most models these days okay all right so uh we covered a bunch of things uh we talked about uh you know floating points and mixed Precision training uh multi-gpu training DDP fsdp uh Laura uh kind of boils down to a very simple flowchart that you can just like use for your project so if you were sleeping
through the entire lecture maybe now it's the time to wake up and just like look at this uh this flowchart um so always use mixed Precision training okay if you have the newer Amper architectures use B float 16 try with the bat size one okay if bat size one fits try a larger bat size and then always just use zero stage two okay bad size one doesn't fit uh try zero stage three uh maybe try gradient checkpointing activation checkpointing uh sorry there's a question this is assuming we have more than one GPU
because doesn't help us oh yeah so all of this applies only if you have more than one GPU yeah if you have a single GPU yeah you have to do other things maybe have to like heavily uh quantize the model and even then I don't think you can uh fine tune some of the bigger bigger models yeah um so assuming you have multiple gpus uh you can try zero stage three if you have uh out of memory errors with a bat size of one if that doesn't work you can try Laura okay and the main hyperparameters in Laura are
the alpha the rank and what uh weight matrices to apply Lura to apply that to the query Matrix apply that to the value Matrix set rank to eight okay that's a good starting point set Alpha to one okay just do that and you should be good to go okay so you can find tun your models and things should be reasonably good okay so uh I'm going to end now unless there's questions um oh there's one question in the back diamides I was wondering if you just like go back to it and walk through it a
little bit on step uh sorry on slide 48 yeah this diagram from the last right uh okay um so let's go through this diagram so basically uh what this diagram shows is how the communication overhead is really not that bad if you have a fairly big model such that the the time it takes to do a forward pass you can already sort of prefetch uh all of the parameters for the next layer okay so that's pretty much the idea so that's kind of like a standard idea that I guess everyone should already be using
like you want to make sure and pyos does this by default by the way like you want to make sure that you know um you sort of fully saturate your GPU uh and then sort of make sure that you uh kind of overlay that with any additional compute you're doing and that's pretty much what's going on here but let's sort of go through this kind of Step by Step okay and so the starting point here is uh fsdp units so 0o one and two are different fsdp units okay so um what you start by doing is um you want to run a
forward pass on the first layer you don't have the first layer okay so let's say you are gpuk you don't have the first layer so you have to do an all gather to get all of the parameters for the first layer so that's ag0 okay at the end of ag0 every GPU has the full set of parameters for uh the layers corresponding to fsdp unit Zer let's just say that's layer that's layer one okay or let's just say that's layer zero okay so you have the full parameters for layer zero you run a
forward pass so that's the stuff in blue and while you're running a forward pass through the first layer you're going to be smart about uh communication overheads and while you're running that you're going to prefetch uh the parameters for the next fsdp unit okay so let's say Layer Two is a different fsdp unit so that's a G1 okay and so you can see that there is like a little bit of overlap between um between F zero and ag1 okay at the end of getting all of the parameters for layer one uh you're
going to do a forward pass okay and so on and then you're going to do AG uh ag2 uh and at the same time uh now let's say you just have way tooo many uh parameters on your GPU okay so you're going to do a little bit of uh like memory free uh you're going to free up some memory okay so that's the stuff in uh in yellow okay and so that's how that goes so you know you basically overlay all gather operations with the forward pass okay and that's how you run the forward pass okay so the communication
overhead is really not that bad if you have like a really big uh deep neural network uh and uh assuming that you have uh um kind of shoted everything properly okay um and then you start the backward pass so in the backward pass uh uh I guess it's a little bit tricky uh cuz you know you want to do these uh all gather operations to get the full gradient so let's say it's a 10 layer neural network okay so you want to compute the full gradient at layer 10 you need to do an all gather operation
to get all of the gradients or to get all of the parameters at layer 10 and then you have to do a reduced scatter okay so you have four gpus everyone has the full set of parameters at layer 10 they have different gradients and so they have to kind of merge their gradients and then sort of split them up to the right GPU and so that's the reduced scatter uh but that's not too bad because you can still like overlay uh reduce scatter operations with the backward pass okay and so that's what
you see happening in the backward pass there okay um and then like along with these forward and backward path uh at sort of um you know regular intervals you have to make sure that you kind of free up GPU memory so for example once you have run a forward pass through layer one now you're on to Layer Two you don't need anything in layer one so you just like free up uh the memory in layer one okay that's pretty much the idea of behind this diagram um so there's a few details here um one of the
details is like in fsdp uh unit zero is sort of treated differently so you'll see that unit zero is never freed up uh that's just sort of an implementation detail in fsdp I'll just quickly say one more thing about fsdp and take a question okay so uh the presentation here makes it seem like it's so simple and that it can be applied to any any neural network right but uh turns out that that's not the full picture so you need to do this kind of uh like you need to kind of divide up your neural network
into fsdp units okay and depending on how you uh depending on what policy you use for dividing up your parameters into fsdp units there's different communication overheads okay so for example it makes sense to kind of uh have like multiple like consecutive layers in the same fsdp unit and so on and so this is like very architecture specific so when you start to use this in pytorch you'll see that the fsdp uh wrapper requires a sort of a sharding policy uh and that is like very architecture specific so because
everyone uses Transformers now they're like very sort of you know handcrafted fine-tuned policies for Transformer like for for creating fsdp units and and shotting strategies for Transformers but let's say you want to you know for your final project you came up with a new architecture sub quadratic attention whatever maybe it's not going to be as efficient just because you don't have the right shot policy okay so that's like one detail about fsdp uh that that maybe you want to keep in mind okay uh
you have a question just a clarification when you mentioned uh you can throw away the weights that you don't need after each layer forward FS but then when you compute backward FS you stream them back in each time uh or do you sort of cash some or cash recent or is there any cashing going on or do you throw them all way and streaming all back uh so there might be some caching but uh uh in in the system but uh the idea is that you just sort of throw them away or at least to the user it it seems like
you've thrown it all away in terms of like uh GPU Ram utilization and then we stream them each layer again and so that's why it's important to like Shard it properly right so for example if like every consecutive layer is you know is like shoted such that it's on multiple gpus then you kind of always are communicating right as opposed to you know you kind of did like uh all gather and then all of the sort of next three layers are loaded in okay so that's why like you know how you
Shard and this like Shing policy becomes important okay okay so if there's no more questions uh let's uh let's end early uh thank you so much [Applause]